salut vous allez bien nous ça va super à
l'égout à la pêche celui-là c'est pas
important avec ses creux
ah oui ça accroche
parce que c'est
bon ça fait du poids
au sein pas étonnant c'est que ça amène
des alternateurs et du cuivre ah oui
sympa
marteau assemat 7 bravo belle trouvaille
ça faisait longtemps un
manche en bois
et des morceaux de ferraille à une
cuillère belles trouvailles
on dirait que c'est du métal argenté
je lis ouais bon c'est la dépollution
est bien bien
arrête arrête de ja pélata juste à
traverser à l'étaler dans vos tout à
l'heure à star
est vraiment
et tout à l'heure il va se baigner
maintenant il veut plus faire ça et bien
avant l'autre côté ils risquent de plus
galérer
saute la la ouais
ouais c'est un peu de la vous mais ça va
lui je te le fais passer dans l'eau et
tu la trappe
à l'époque
et
bien
c'est bien
voilà
allez va aller à ton tour
non
pas les petits joli joli belle entrée en
matière c'est n'importe quoi
non
ici on avait trouvé un chargeur ça sert
baptiste
donc peut-être on va trouver le pistolet
ouais
attend
ça ressemble à un méchant
il est à deux otages étaient dangereux
tu as vu il est hélas ils sont
vulnérables aux
élus tout petit barbare un malheur un
style copains ça les regarde il part
avec eux s'ils lui en faut peu farceur
des amis à lui
voit donc la petite 3 une sorte de
broches prince non c'est pas sympa au
grave
la jolie ils regardent et reste de
cambriolage est une règle 1 m s approcha
peine du coup tombera ce léger at-on
collier
façade est du toc un ouais ça a l'air
d'être justement les rejeter tu as vu il
ya des trucs qui accroche un peu ouais
sympa de jeter récemment alors parce que
si c'est aimanté et que c'est pas
rouillé et que ça raccroche ouais bah
c'est bien belle trouvaille est en tout
cas c'est rigolo calme vous trouvez ça
c'est bien
doucement
ou ce chien
doucement resta
highco et ses nouveaux copains
ouest ah oui c'est ça paquette
achète une plaquette de frein
à plat et
parce que c est nul et une météorite
un sapin n'est pas une garde quand même
on l'a dit on sait jamais allée bâti je
crois en toi tu vas y arriver c'est
toujours vous tombez dans l'eau à temps
ses prêts
au
super vélo
j'étais obligé
un
savoir ou là
ah oui
jamais vu ça
ovo jolie away ses supports de
faras tinqueux
[Musique]
venir avec temps qui sourire la rasta au
site a vu
rouge et quelque chose
twitter
pas mal mais ya pas de larmes on dirait
oui petit pour jouer au hockey avec le
langage
à meylan le poids 10 trucs
qui sicap accroché s'accorde à
l'alhambra fiable
haïti peut tenter ça on l'a voit il
faudrait une branche
plus de la pêche à l'errance et de la
pêche à la branche a bien joué
mais il a l'air énorme il ya le manche
avec way où il n'est pas vieux lui
oh ça c'est être énormes demeurent sains
pour devant
bath et peut-être de la marque
quelque chose froid
aux yeux une pince
waouh ça fait vieux
ouah c'est vraiment d'époque un
ah ouais
mais je suis pas sûr stationné toute
entière mais tu vas dire aura star tu
viennes pas ce qu'est mon moule
à quelque chose au
détonateur de grenade bon pas trop faire
le con et que ça allait y entend la
goupille
aïe aïe aïe
bon no cry a marqué s
ses fils
oui oui oui c'est sûr oui ça a été
séparée à la main il suffit de dévisser
en faut quand même pas faire le contre
le détonateur change de spots
alors qu'est ce tu viens de trouver les
gars là oui il ya la terre qui est assez
ouais il ya deux choses une grosse
fabuler et une deuxième place qui peut
mettre de l'essence aurait gardé yahvé
s'est accroché à leyment away est
récente c'est de la grenaille bon
mauvaise nouvelle il ya de l'essence qui
sort un mauvaise nouvelle pour le canal
parce que nous ce n'est qu'en même temps
on va voir dépolluer ouf c'est lourd ça
vient mais c'est lourd oh ça va bien
aller
ça a lâché là ça paraît
on l'a bien avant c'est vrai et encore
ah ouais ça y est c'est le cadre
wheadon quoi il ya plusieurs parties je
pense qu'ils nous ont découpé tout ça
on a enfin réussi à attraper le gros
morceau passe unique avait de l'essence
lui hier avant
ça fait un peu bizarre ouais
ah ah
enfin
voilà on a le moteur je crois alors
attends
au c'est un énorme tas dans
un pas énorme mais un beau cadre
nickel
lundi
ali
ben ben oui un réservoir
ouais ok super ça plus les sens et pas
tout neuf va pas laisser couler pense
qu'elle a déjà coulé c'est de l'eau
mélangée moi aussi vous savez en
commentaire quel modèle s'est dit nous
alléger rattraper l'autre morceau
me semble mais comme ça après my
way est à moitié en alu c'est sous la
halle et c'est peut-être bien la hat a
carrément le moteur en fait ouais
documentaire
ça aussi qui mettez les sur tout ça et
donc c'est le même luiz vraiment oui
encore une fois ils ont volé pour pas
garder grand chose non c'était
hélas tu vois c'est là tu as les numéros
de série je pense donc automatiquement
ils peuvent pas garder sa très bonne
dépollution bien joué
voilà la vidéo est terminée donc merci à
ceux qui l'ont regardé et ceux qui ne
sont pas encore abonnés n'hésitez pas à
le faire ça nous motive énormément pour
continuer et on se dit ah la semaine
prochaine